A finales del mes de marzo de 2023, Hiroshi
Nishiyama, un ejecutivo de 50 años que trabaja
para Astellas Pharma, una de las farmacéuticas
más grandes de Japón, desapareció, se esfumó
Lo hizo en su último día en China, justo
antes de regresar a tierras niponas tras 20
años trabajando en el gigante asiático.
Claro que, poco después, se supo por qué
había desaparecido: el señor Nishiyama había
sido detenido por la policía china que le
acusaba, ni más ni menos, que de ser un espía.
O al menos, de participar en actividades de
espionaje.
El problema, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
no es, ya que podamos dudar o no de su fundamento,
el problema es que es el decimoctavo japonés
detenido y acusado de lo mismo desde el año
2015.
De hecho, las sospechas y las ecuaciones de
espionaje se han convertido en toda una moda
en este país.
N1(15 de mayo de 2023: China condena a un
ciudadano estadounidense a cadena perpetua
por espionaje.
WSJ)
Y ojo, porque la moda del espionaje no solo
afecta a casos aislados.
Los medios de comunicación estatales han
puesto en la diana a las empresas de consultoría
y auditoria, muchas de las cuales estarían
siendo investigadas por las agencias de seguridad
nacional.
Esto ha hecho que, por ejemplo, en la Encuesta
de Riesgo Político que elabora Oxford Analítica
entre varias multinacionales, China se haya
convertido ya en el segundo país con mayor
riesgo político del mundo, tan solo por detrás
de Rusia.
Esto también ayuda a explicar, lo que ya
os hemos dicho un montón de veces, que aunque
China sigue siendo un destino importantísimo,
cada vez más empresas están estudiando como
diversificar su actividad productiva en este
país.
Y es que puede que no esté teniendo un gran
impacto mediático, pero lo cierto es que
las últimas decisiones del gobierno chino
están haciendo saltar las alarmas en muchas
multinacionales.
Hablamos, incluso, de un cambio en la Ley
de contraespionaje que puede poner en el ojo
del huracán a un montón de empresas y profesionales.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué demonios está pasando
en China?
¿Por qué están saltando muchas alertas
rojas?
¿Está el gobierno de Xi Jinping utilizando
la legislación sobre espionaje para presionar,
castigar o cortar lazos con algunas empresas
extranjeras?
¿Qué puede suponer todo esto para el futuro
económico de la República Popular China?
Pues…
Prestad mucha atención, porque en este vídeo
os vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas.
Y lo primero, lo primero es saber dónde empezó
todo.
T1(EL CERROJAZO)
Todo empezó en el año 2014, apenas un año
después de qué Xi Jinping se convirtiera
en el Presidente todopoderoso de China, con
titulares como este:
N2(El Parlamento chino aprueba una ley de
contraespionaje.
La nueva ley define el espionaje y otorga
a las agencias de seguridad nacional autoridad
para confiscar bienes.
WSJ)
Esta nueva ley sustituía a la Ley de Seguridad
Nacional de 1993 y le concedió a las agencias
de seguridad nacional la capacidad de detener
y perseguir las actividades que a su juicio
se consideraran perjudiciales para…
La Seguridad Nacional.
También permitía la incautación de bienes
y propiedades y el derecho a confiscar cualquier
dispositivo, dinero o bien cualquier tipo
que estuviera relacionado con el espionaje.
A Xi Jinping le gusta tenerlo atado y bien
atado.
Así que por supuesto, tras aprobarse esta
ley comenzaron…
las detenciones.
Por ejemplo, el 15 de julio de 2016, cuando
estaba a punto de tomar un avión de regreso
a Japón, el investigador Hideji Suzuki fue
detenido.
No sabía el motivo.
Le acusaron de ser un espía.
En el juicio se enteró de que una de las
razones es haberle preguntado a un colega
que era funcionario chino si sabía algo de
la supuesta ejecución por parte de Kim Jong
Un de su tío.
Al final no hubo mucha historia, pero fue
condenado a 6 años de cárcel.
¿Las condiciones?
Él mismo lo cuenta.
C1(“La parte más difícil fue durante los
primeros siete meses de mi detención.
Las cortinas estaban cerradas en esa habitación.
Solo pude ver el sol durante 15 minutos con
un permiso especial.
Lloré cuando lo vi".
Hideji Suzuki)
En 2017 cuatro empleados de la NC Geophysical
Survey y dos empleados de otra empresa local
también fueron detenidos.
En 2018 las autoridades chinas reaccionaron
al arresto por parte de Canadá de la directora
financiera de Huawei, Meng Wanzhou, deteniendo
a dos canadienses por cargos de espionaje,
aunque no se presentaron evidencia.
Son solo tres ejemplos de muchos más casos.
Claro que eso tan solo fue el comienzo.
Sobre todo en los últimos años, el gobierno
chino se ha puesto las pilas para incrementar
su control sobre casi todo.
En 2021, la Administración del Ciberespacio
de China presento muchas nuevas restricciones
a la exportación de datos…
Restricciones que pasaron a estar en vigor
a partir del día 1 de septiembre de 2022
y que ya le están complicando mucho la vida
a un montón de empresas y profesionales de
todo tipo.
Por ejemplo, estas normas están restringiendo
el acceso de empresas, inversores y profesionales
a información contable de empresas chinas,
a información sobre patentes, revistas académicas
o series estadísticas de todo tipo.
Este es, por ejemplo, el caso de la base de
datos más importante de todo el país, la
que maneja la Wind Information con sede en
Shanghái, una enorme fuente de datos económicos
y financieros que hasta ahora era ampliamente
utilizado por analistas e inversores extranjeros.
Sin embargo, eso se está volviendo cada vez
más complicado.
En la misma línea, en 2019, otro investigador
de la Universidad de Hokkaido también fue
detenido.
Hoy cinco japoneses están detenidos en China
por acusaciones muy similares de espionaje.
Hace no mucho tiempo los empleados de la oficina
en Shanghái de la consultora norteamericana
Bain & Company fueron interrogados.
En otra consultora estadounidense, Mintz Group
,detuvieron a cinco trabajadores y en marzo
de 2023 Pekín anunció una revisión de ciberseguridad
contra la empresa de semiconductores estadounidense
Micron Technology.
Una revisión que ha terminado prohibiendo
la comercialización de varios de los productos
de esta empresa en el país.
De la misma forma, la policía también visitó
por sorpresa la oficia de la empresa norteamericana
de networking y consultoría, Capvision.
Queridos amigos, el gobierno chino se ha obsesionado
con los datos.
Y eso es, exactamente, lo que explica noticias
como esta:
N3(China encierra la información sobre el
país en una caja negra.
WSJ)
Con todo, la medida potencialmente más importante
y cuyas repercusiones pueden llegar a ser
mucho más graves llegó con el comienzo del
segundo trimestre del 2023.
Fijaos.
N4(China aprueba una amplia expansión de
la ley de lucha contra el espionaje.
Reuters)
Queridos amigos, el 26 de abril, el principal
órgano legislativo, la Asamblea Popular Nacional,
aprobó una importantísima reforma de la
ley de contraespionaje del 2014.
Una reforma que ha hecho saltar las alarmas
de empresas, inversores y gobiernos de todo
el mundo.
La pregunta es, ¿por qué?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Presta mucha atención porque las repercusiones
de este cambio pueden llegar a ser mucho más
importantes de lo que imaginas.
[Por cierto, un apunte.
Echando un vistazo a las estadísticas hemos
que visto que todavía más del 40% de las
personas que veis VisualPolitik no estáis
suscritas al canal.
La pregunta es, ¿A qué estáis esperando?
Si os gusta la política, la economía, los
asuntos internacionales, ir directamente a
las claves que nos permiten entender lo que
ocurre en el mundo y, además, pasar un buen
rato, no dejéis de suscribiros y activar
la campanita.
Es 100% gratuito]
T2(¿EL GOLPE DEFINITIVO?)
Queridos amigos, amigas, la última reforma
de la ley de contraespionaje de China ha hecho
saltar todas las alarmas.
La pregunta es, ¿Por qué?
Pues básicamente porque esta reforma incorpora
5 grandes cambios:
Primero, se amplía el alcance de la ley a
todos los documentos, datos, materiales o
artículos que a juicio del gobierno puedan
estar relacionados con la seguridad y los
intereses, nacionales.
Sin importar que sean públicos o privados.
Porque de hecho la ley ni siquiera define
en que consiste o qué ámbitos quedan bajo
el concepto de seguridad nacional.
¿Y qué quiere decir esto?
Pues lo vamos a ver en un momento, pero básicamente
que todo queda al arbitrio del gobierno.
Segundo, la reforma también refuerza el control
sobre el ciberespacio.
Tercero, se le concede más poder a los cuerpos
de seguridad para inspeccionar e incautar
el equipaje y los dispositivos electrónicos
de cualquier persona que pueda ser sospechosa
de tratar con datos delicados.
Cuatro, todos los ciudadanos y organizaciones
chinas tendrán que denunciar cualquiera “sospecha”
de espionaje a riesgo de ser considerados
cómplices si no lo hacen.
Y ya sabéis lo que esto puede suponer…
Básicamente, esto puede hacer que cualquier
conducta pueda llegar a ser considerada sospecha.
Luego veremos algún ejemplo.
C2("Los académicos extranjeros como yo ahora
evitarán ir a China si podemos, porque cosas
como los comentarios en las redes sociales
podrían verse como evidencia de haber cometido
espionaje a los ojos del gobierno chino".
Tomoko Ako, académico de la Universidad de
Tokio)
Y quinto, se prohibirá la salida del país
a cualquier persona, ojo, nacional o, incluso,
llegado el caso, extranjera, que esté bajo
investigación - no procesada - o que se considere
que su salida supone un riesgo para la seguridad
nacional.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según datos
de Reuters, entre los años 2016 y 2022 se
multiplicó por 8 el número de prohibiciones
de salida, así que imaginaos lo que puede
suponer a partir de ahora esta reforma.
Pero, un momento, ¿por qué está ley ha
desatado tantas alarmas?
Pues sobre todo porque se entromete de lleno
en el funcionamiento de las empresas privadas.
La ley ya no solo habla de secretos de estado,
sino de cualquier tipo de información y datos.
Y claro, el problema es que cualquier empresa
para poder funcionar más o menos correctamente
necesita que sus ejecutivos tengan información:
Necesitan conocer las tendencias de la industria,
las preferencias de los consumidores, sus
niveles de ahorro, las patentes que se están
publicando, los diseños industriales generados
por la propia empresa, los datos de sus rivales,
etcétera, etcétera.
Sin embargo, ahora tener ese tipo de información
puede suponer un enorme problema.
Y lo mismo ocurre con las empresas que tengan
asociadas: auditores, consultores o abogados.
Ahora si son extranjeros tienen que trabajar
con un tipo de información que podría llegar
a meterlos en la cárcel…
Tras un juicio que en el caso de las acusaciones
de espionaje se realiza en secreto.
Sin luces ni taquígrafos.
Es decir, en otras palabras, que ahora cualquier
persona que haya manejado información delicada
de un proyecto o una empresa en China podría
llegar a ser acusado ni más ni menos que
por la Ley de contraespionaje.
Ni siquiera se requiere que se acredite su
trabajo para una potencia extranjera.
Y esto, esto es un importante problema, porque
prácticamente cualquier persona puede llegar
a ser arrestada y culpada de cargos de espionaje.
Qué, lógicamente, es de lo peor que te puede
pasar en la mayor parte de países del mundo,
y especialmente en autocracias como la china.
("Se ha hecho aún más difícil prever la
situación, y las empresas se verán obligadas
a ser más cautelosas en muchos aspectos".
​​Director de la Asociación Japonesa
de Ejecutivos de Empresa)
C4(La actualización de la ley contra el espionaje
del PCCh envía una señal alta y clara al
mundo: en China no existen las empresas privadas.
El Estado se reserva el derecho de confiscar
arbitrariamente cualquier propiedad, robar
cualquier propiedad intelectual, recopilar
cualquier dato.
Congresista republicano, Mike Gallagher, Presidente
del Comité Selecto sobre el Partido Comunista
Chino)
Y no solo eso, la propia emisora pública
CCTV ha cargado contra empresas de consultoría
por, supuestamente, causar daño a la seguridad
nacional.
Así que ahora, por ejemplo, para evitar ser
acusados de espionaje en cualquier momento,
las empresas, los ejecutivos y los inversores
tendrán que trabajar con los datos oficiales
que el gobierno decida publicar, sin poder
intentar obtener y recopilar información
por sí mismos…
Salvo que se requieran arriesgar a terminar
en el trullo.
Y eso, esto es solo una de las muchas posibles
consecuencias.
Además, ahora cualquiera “acusación”
por el motivo que sea, puede terminar con
las agencias de seguridad nacional registrando
los dispositivos electrónicos y las oficinas
de las empresas extranjeras, lo que podría
exponer secretos comerciales y propiedad intelectual.
Y, ¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Teniendo en cuenta el historial de China en
esta materia…
mucho ojo.
Y en Estados Unidos este es un tema que genera
cada vez más y más inquietud.
C5(“Nuestros dirigentes empresariales tienen
que quitarse la venda dorada de los ojos y
reconocer que las recientes redadas policiales
en las empresas estadounidenses Bain y Mintz
no son casos aislados, sino que forman parte
de una larga y altiva tradición de explotación.
Congresista republicano, Mike Gallagher)
C6(" El Congreso debería aprobar una legislación
que faculte a la Comisión de Valores y Bolsa
para limitar el flujo de fondos a China.
El esfuerzo debe disfrutar de un apoyo bipartidista".
George Soros)
Claro que, dicho esto, la pregunta que seguro
muchos os estáis haciendo es…
¿Por qué?
¿Qué gana el gobierno chino poniendo en
la diana la información y los datos privados?
Pues… probablemente nada.
Pero en Pekín están obsesionados fundamentalmente
con tres cosas:
Primero, tal y como defiende el activista,
experto legal y profesor de la Universidad
de Ciencias Políticas y Derecho de China
en Pekín, Teng Biao, con todo este control
el gobierno quiere evitar que las potencias
extranjeras puedan llegar a instigar una revolución
de colores en China.
Y vale, puede que penseis que no es que parezca
lo más probable del mundo.
Pero sea como sea en Pekín, parecen obsesionados
con tener el control y evitar que nada pueda
afectar al actual régimen.
Si todas las empresas están atadas en corto,
mejor que mejor.
Segundo, el gobierno quiere controlar la narrativa
sobre el estado real de la economía china.
La economía china no atraviesa su mejor momento:
el desempleo juvenil está batiendo récords,
solo crece la inversión pública y el sector
exterior se está desacelerando.
¿Quiere decir esto que el milagro chino está
llegando a su fin?
Por si las moscas en Pekín tienen claro que
cuenta menos se sepa mejor que mejor.
Y tercero, el gobierno también quiere impedir
a toda costa que los datos de las empresas,
de la industria y de las tecnológicas de
China abandonen el país para ser usados por
rivales del resto del mundo.
Ahora bien, la pregunta qué seguro, seguro,
muchos os estáis haciendo es…
¿Y cómo puede afectar todo esto a la economía
china?
¿Es que acaso en Pekín quieren conseguir
que las empresas extranjeras se larguen del
país?
Pues nada más lejos de la realidad.
Atentos.
T3(¿BRAZOS ABIERTOS?)
Ya lo veis.
Estamos ante el último gran quebradero de
cabeza que el régimen del Partido Comunista
chino le está provocando a las empresas extranjeras
en el país, y también a las propias empresas
locales.
Claro que esta no es la primera zancadilla.
En los últimos años, hemos visto, por ejemplo,
la guerra que el gobierno de Xi Jinping desató
contra las grandes tecnológicas chinas.
Comenzó a finales de 2020 cuando Pekín paralizó
la salida a bolsa del brazo financiero de
Alibaba tras unas declaraciones críticas
de Jack Ma que fueron algo así como la gota
que colmó el vaso para los gerifaltes de
Pekín.
A partir de ese momento se lanzó una campaña
de nuevas reglas, multas, límites, boqueo
a operaciones corporativas y mucho más control
de todas estas empresas por parte del Partido
Comunista.
¿Su objetivo?
Limitar el poder cada vez mayor que estos
grupos estaban acaparando en el país.
[Atreverse a criticar a Xi Jinping, dónde
se habrá visto]
Y no solo eso.
Poco después, el 17 de agosto de 2021, se
impulsó el conocido Plan para la Prosperidad
Común para limitar los beneficios excesivos
que, según el gobierno, muchas empresas estaban
teniendo.
Es decir, por primera vez en muchos años
el gobierno chino volvió a poner en la diana
los beneficios de las empresas.
Pero…
Seguimos.
Al mismo tiempo, el gobierno chino también
comenzó a reforzar su presencia en el capital
y sobre todo en la dirección de las grandes
compañías.
Para que os hagáis una idea, ahora tanto
las empresas estatales como las privadas tienen
al máximo nivel - incluso por encima del
presidente de la propia empresa- a un representante
del partido para fiscalizar y participar en
la toma de decisiones.
Son solo 3 ejemplos a los que se suman toneladas
de nueva regulación y ahora, también, la
reforma de la ley de contraespionaje que hemos
visto.
Y claro, con todo esto en mente…
La pregunta, la gran pregunta que parece estar
sobre la mesa es: ¿Es que acaso el gobierno
chino quiere espantar a las empresas privadas?
Pues, lo más sorprendente de todo es que
aparentemente no.
Todos estos planes chocan de frente con las
otras dos grandes prioridades del gobierno:
convertir a China en la gran referencia económica
del mundo y, sobre todo, en el corto plazo,
alentar nuevas inversiones extranjeras para
impulsar su economía y superar todos los
baches en los que están metidos.
C7(“Todo el mundo quiere que invirtamos
más.
Parece un poco como si la mano izquierda no
supiera lo que está haciendo la mano derecha”.
Jörg Wuttke, presidente de la Cámara de
Comercio de la Unión Europea en China.)
De hecho, el Primer Ministro de China se encuentra
en plena campaña para intentar mejorar la
imagen del país y no se cansa de repetir,
una y otra y otra vez, que "China está abierta
a los negocios”.
C8("El gobierno chino ha dicho continuamente
que da la bienvenida a la inversión extranjera.
Sin embargo, una oleada de acciones recientes
tomadas de nuevo por las empresas estadounidenses
en China ha enviado el mensaje opuesto".
Michael Hart, presidente de la Cámara de
Comercio Americana en China)
Es la gran contradicción del gobierno chino.
Una contradicción que está haciendo que,
por ejemplo, por primera vez en los últimos
25 años, en la encuesta de sentimiento empresarial
de la Cámara de Comercio americana en China,
la mayoría de las empresas hayan respondido
que ya no ven a China como uno de los tres
destinos prioritarios de inversión.
Sí, este país seguirá siendo clave por
su enorme mercado y las empresas internacionales
seguirán invirtiendo mucho dinero en él,
pero cada vez parece más claro que esta apuesta,
está perdiendo fuerza.
Si antes la idea era invertir en China para
atender desde allí todo el mercado mundial,
ahora la idea es que las inversiones en China
atiendan esencialmente el mercado chino.
Por ahí parece que van los tiros.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Esto no es nada bueno para China.
[Que es, por otra parte lo que explica la
campaña del Primer Ministro]
Pero si os parece fijémonos en algunos datos:
Como podéis ver, el desempleo juvenil está
batiendo récords.
Entre ellos hablamos de casi 12 millones de
titulados universitarios…
Y eso a pesar de que el envejecimiento haya
hecho que la población activa del país haya
caído en los últimos 3 años en más de
40 millones de personas.
La cosa, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
se está poniendo tan fea que las visitas
a los templos se han multiplicado por 4.
La mitad de los visitantes son jóvenes nacidos
a partir de 1990 que van allí a rezar, hacer
ofrendas, por un trabajo.
No es broma.
Por su parte, los medios estatales han puesto
en marcha una campaña para recriminar a los
graduados universitarios que no acepten empleos
en actividades como la construcción, el campo
o la hostelería.
Y no es un problema aislado.
N5("La segunda economía más grande del mundo
no se está disparando en todos los campos.
El gasto de los consumidores se está recuperando,
pero la fabricación está retrocediendo y
las ganancias industriales están cayendo.
El crecimiento de los ingresos de los hogares
es débil y el desempleo juvenil está cerca
de un máximo histórico".
Bloomberg.)
Así que ya lo veis.
Ahora la reforma de la ley de contraespionaje
promete echar más gasolina al fuego.
Las reformas chinas están empezando a complicarle
y mucho la vida a las empresas justo en el
momento en el que más necesitan a las empresas
y la inversión de las empresas.
De locos.
Os contaremos muchos más detalles sobre el
estado de China, tanto en nuestro boletín
para patronos como en NotNews, nuestra newsletter
abierta y gratuita para todo el mundo.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
La pregunta es: ¿Merece la pena que las empresas
occidentales sigan invirtiendo en China?
¿Mantendrán sus inversiones o reducirán
su apuesta por el gigante asiático?
¿Cómo puede afectar esto a China?
¿Vosotros qué haríais?
Dejadnos vuestras impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima..